good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast our final live show for
the week because after this show Jackie
and I are embarking on a treacherous but
hopefully branches Jenny a treacherous
but hopefully fruitful journey that will
you know just have memories that last a
lifetime but at the end of the day that
might not happen in Jackie and I just
might be stranded in the desert from
we'll see we're heading to Coachella we
have flight so hopefully we don't get
stranded I don't know why I'm just like
having terrible anxiety that like once
we get there like everything will stop
working do you know I'm having trouble
anxiety that once I get there I won't
like look good you know I mean that's
like right now that's the least of my
worries because I'm just worried about
surviving about mine looks like I either
am well prepared or underprepared I have
no idea well into US fashion we made it
to the very last minute I mean actually
that's not true I've been preparing for
quite a few weeks and then I found
myself yesterday with absolutely no
clothing options so Jackie and I hit the
town yesterday to a quite you know
really lackluster selection at H&M and
then I have to say I did have to drive
to Times Square 45th and 7th to go to
the forever 21 but was it fruitful or
was it fruitful first of all because she
thought after weeks of searching she
finally found the Coachella section
every time I would walk into a store I
was like hi where's the Coachella
section and they're like but but all of
forever 20 when it was four floors of a
Coachella section I saw a toaster in the
wild mr. pops I could she just like
looked at me from across the sword she
was like she knows she gave a showed her
phone with the Pops on it
it was truly wonderful and they just had
so much neon so much arid essence so
much fringe so much kimonos so I'm
really going for like a kimono vibe cool
exciting hopefully so yes after this we
embark on a treacherous journey
yesterday we had Blake on the show and
the power went out and it was so sad and
just want to apologize and all the fun
as everyone else all the audio is in the
podcast so you can finish the episode
where he describes if jason is a vampire
very importantly show her ass he didn't
say that he was no and it was like
almost like that feeling when you ask
someone a question and it's like button
the belief that like oh I'm not the only
one thinking this I felt like he felt
like ooh you know I have fellow
conspiracy theory things with like you
know I really liked him michio he was
major cutie I think him and Margo vibes
I'm seeing maybe like
moment for them at Coachella I mean at
stagecoach but we'll say you know and I
just loved that he worked in New York
City me too that's a brave man we also
promote a singer on the show today she's
gonna be over here talking all things
for Honi ageless by Ramona which is her
new skincare line which I assume they
found a lab at a formula for is you do
we have remember how she's going okay
cool no I mean her person confirmed
yesterday so like okay well you know if
he doesn't come like she lives in New
York we know where to find her no I just
you know what like you have a feeling
about some of them that just like not
gonna show up yeah you know when you
have a feeling you're kind of hoping cuz
you can cuz I'm nervous for Ramona I'm
so excited for Ramona last night's
episode of Roni was so funny when Sonja
Morgan she got drunk and she they went
to the Morgan house and it was like oh
oh my god and when she started talking
she sounded like the Irish weather woman
to know taken risks on dredgers right
and when she said the thing about the
more she's like you don't [ __ ] we
touched the Morgan letters open the way
she said letters I was laughing for a
minute straight I oh my god I it was it
was a wonderful moment I'm very excited
to talk to Ramona she's just you know
she's got some some splainin to do if
you know what I'm saying she's she's
been saying stuff every episode that's
just right neither here nor there the
average girl is huge apparently about
average American girl she was like
American the average American is big the
average girl is huge no she just meant
like there's an obesity problem in our
country but she said it in the most
insensitive way for sure but like she
wasn't wrong no but you have a problem
in America with with obesity yeah but
there's just a way to say it and I just
said it you know right but she's my mama
singer
yeah well me it's it's gonna make for an
interesting show if Ramona shows up I
don't know why I'm just like feeling
like she's not going to let me check my
email one second we'll keep you posted
and we have a great show for you
otherwise cuz honestly there were a lot
of stories I had a hard time whittling
it down to five did you yes and the one
that had to go but I just want to
mention it because Julian Assange has
been someone that we've always been
confused about on the show right weren't
sure who was Julius and who was Elon
Musk which ones dating Pamela Anderson
now that Elon Musk has firmly defined
himself as a psychopath we obviously
know who he is but like two years ago I
was genuinely confused it's like what
Julian Assange did for a living like how
Elon Musk paid his bills like what
doesn't ask to have to do with it now I
know but I'm just want to say like I
started off being really confused
right so we can close the book on this
because Julian Assange has been arrested
in Ecuador for what for computer hacking
charges he is that Snowden
no but it's Snowden vibes except that I
think Snowden like he worked for the
government and was hacking stuff whereas
trillion and assigns just I think he was
chief WikiLeaks
yeah he's WikiLeaks he got it okay okay
well so Grayson he's being arrested for
all the wiki's that he leaked I actually
should that and I know Pamela Anderson I
guess they're still friendly and she's
really upset about it she was tweeting
like some crazy stuff about the US
Britain Ecuador cuz he was living in
Ecuador and then when he walked into the
embassy he got arrested but it's just
crazy crazy stuff for Julian Assange I
can't wait to see the movie on it so I
know what's going also I just want make
a correction he was arrested in London
at the Ecuadorian Embassy in London
that's confusing why is he hanging out
with Ecuadorian Embassy because he was
at one point living in Ecuador I don't
think that I made that up maybe he
doesn't make people work or something
but maybe I did but it's like why now
why this embassy did you did they give
him up I don't know that's why we just
need the movie who do you think would
play Julian Assange let me show you a
photo okay so as you say honestly he
looks like David Letterman
oh he's old yeah he looks like Sir
Roderick oh my god it looks like a rabbi
okay but I think it's cuz he's been like
living in underground but I think when
he was doing the leaking he was like
young and hot I thought so too like
Julian is a hot name oh you're showing
me like I'm her friend
I'm showing me one of the reporters in
the back I'm showing you nothing you
know nothing Jon Snow Julian assigned
like young joy brunette Julian Assange
is what we need
oh he looks like anyone from Game of
Thrones could Pike okay that's a great
photo oh he has white hair I didn't know
that he should be the guy from Desperate
Housewives Dave okay or wait I just
thought of to make show me him again I
thought of two guys who is the actor
Victor Garber oh yeah Victor Garber
or or John Boy amazing Wow nailed it
amazing
I thought Julian Assange was young and
brunette he's old and gray who no you
thought he was Elon Musk right see I'm
getting and I actually thought he was
snowed in and who played Snowden Jordan
good Levitt why does if Gordon loved it
yeah oh yeah born 11 Joseph Gordon for
short Jordan anyways
so goodbye Julian
or see you later isn't it weird when
people like become famous and have
movies made after them for being like
people who just have jobs in the
government and like they do bad things
like yeah but the end of the day it's
like just Sally from HR get a movie when
she like tells the company secrets now
how could I leave for me jargon yeah if
she wasn't whistleblower and a big
company she could get a movie yeah at a
big company that's what I'm saying like
Snowden and Assange like they're famous
for just like being losers who work in
the government and like I took took
files they weren't supposed to yeah no
that's Emily Snowden I don't know if
Julian Assange ever worked in the
government so whatever but whatever I
guess that would be just like a famous
hacker yeah famous hacker for sure okay
this weird what people come famous for
you know that was the story that didn't
make the cut sometimes we spoke about oh
I was gonna be I was thinking as we were
talking about it I'm like she's starting
out oh there were so many good stories
this one sucks right dad would say the
makeup and I just something she
mentioned because she wouldn't sign at
one point was a big fixture on the show
okay more so on the old chugger II
agreed so I heard from him and why I
just want to close the book on that so
now that we've done that without further
ado I believe it is time let me check my
watch yes to deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast okay first story exciting
legal news because she uses legal jargon
in everyday life therefore Kim
Kardashian is studying to become a
lawyer she wants to take the bar in 2022
she is also on the cover of Vogue and
she did it seventy-three questions that
I just watched first of all like just
love when when high fashion snobs like
Anna Wintour you know admit that Kim
Kardashian and Kanye have pretty much
influenced all of fashion for the last
five years and the fact that Kim has
never been on vogue solo
he's a craziest thing and when she
posted I was like Oh Kim's on the cover
of Vogue and then I read the caption
she's like it's my first solo cover and
there are just not many things that Kim
hasn't done so for there to be her first
something I think is crazy and just
really like no matter what you say about
her like she and Kanye were wearing
those big puffy shorts and bike a pig
puffy jackets and biker shorts and alien
glasses and we thought it was so weird
now it's what everyone's wearing I'll go
to Coachella see what or now just look
at Vogue like they really have heavily
influenced fashion so much and it's
shocking the chasman on the cover yet I
would be like infuriated if I was her
yeah also they just always do her dirty
this cover is better than the last
oh this cover is good better it's good
it's it's not her at her most beautiful
I don't know why they like it's better
compared to the last one but like if I
were her it would like I don't know at
least her hair is short that's literally
all I'm grateful for because I hate
this long-hair they just doing always
give her like weird makeup ya know she
looks good she is into this like
minimalist like nude vibe on her makeup
so like she definitely I see her in this
eye the cover matches her Instagram flow
you know there's it's very much her
aesthetic yeah so okay but no she could
have been like more glammed up I would
have loved that
but I'm happy with it especially given
the last a vogue that we got where she
just honestly looked horrible and it's
like do you think she she's obviously so
glad she was on the cover of it with
kind of never did she think from sex
tape to vote yes but do you think she's
also like I hate how I look well she's
so obsessed with the way that she looks
and she's open about that so I have to
think but she would never publicly say
that she didn't like it because she was
really just like it was an honor to be
on it and she would never just Ana like
that but like the makeup was bad she
looks like she was crying and there was
a mascara smile was bad the the position
was been honey was hunched over her so
he was [ __ ] up her posture the dress
was bad the lighting some of the photos
in the inside where North was in and
they did a bunch of wedding photos were
cute but the cover was just not cute it
was not cute
okay she looked like she hadn't slept in
months in a new interview with vogue Kim
reveals that she's studying to become a
lawyer and decided last summer to begin
a four year apprenticeship with a law
firm in San Francisco with the goal of
taking the bar in 2022 Kim has been
working with author and CNN commentator
Van Jones an attorney Jessica Jackson
cofounders of hashtag cut 50 a national
bipartisan advocacy group on criminal
justice reform for months visiting
prisons petitioning governors and
attending meetings at the White House
last year she successfully petitioned
President Donald Trump to commute the
life sentence of Alice Marie Johnson a
nonviolent drug offender after Johnson
was released a major bipartisan piece of
criminal justice reform legislation the
first-step Act was passed by Congress
and signed into law by Trump in December
quote I had to think long and hard about
this she says of her decision explaining
that she eventually decided to embark on
the journey after seeing a really good
result with Alice Marie Johnson quote I
never in a million years thought we
would get to the point of getting laws
passed she says that was really a
turning point for me totally from sex
tape to tomorrow still totally no she's
epic I love her and I just some thinking
now about enrolling in law school as
well in California just in the hopes
that we have class together for sure but
she's in
in San Francisco it's that's a big
commute for her why wouldn't she just
apprentice with Robert Shapiro maybe she
can do online classes in the University
of San Francisco maybe and Robert
Shapiro actually a Kia's criminal law Oh
Jay is ya know was so okay well she
wants to get her law degree like to what
what's the ends here like what is she
gonna start defending people it could be
alloyed maybe or maybe there's certain
things that she can't do or document she
can't sign without not the lawyer yeah
and it's like in all of this prep work
for Alice Murray um we saw on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians that's what really
I think she spends like half of her days
now going through cases like this so
she's learning all of this might as well
take the bar if she passes great she's
automatically a lawyer California is one
of the few states where you don't have
to go to law school in order to take the
bar so maybe she didn't move to
California early maybe she's just gonna
take some classes and like learn enough
to pass the bar and not let graduate cuz
you don't have to graduate no and she's
not going to school and you all you've
to do is this apprenticeship what she's
doing and so about 22 she'll take the
bar and then that'll be so crazy to see
it later just gonna pay someone to take
the bar for her oh my god apparently you
can't do that not in this climate not in
that state
it's just crazy because right now she's
doing amazing stuff and it's wild to
think what she'll be doing in 2022 I've
only recently become like super
conscious of the speed at which we speak
yeah and I'm going to now make a
conscious decision to slow down because
for a while I used to talk really fast
and if you couldn't keep up like that's
your problem but now I find myself just
skipping words because I don't have time
for them so it's like my sentences are
truly not English and it's like I'll say
a sentence without ever closing my mouth
cuz I'll just let it I yeah you know I
noticed something about myself too
especially in the pictures that were
taken of us during our soiree and I've
noticed it before but I guess I never
realized how pertinent it is it's like
when I'm talking my mouth is moving like
a crazy
I need like Botox of the mouth because
like if you just take a picture at stamp
one photo of me while I'm talking I look
like this you know my mouth is always
wide open and in pictures around talking
I'm screaming up it's like no I'm just
think it's good to be self-aware and I'm
gonna I'm gonna slow it down at least
just
enunciate a little bit more because I
find myself to be almost a
comprehensive but we the problem is is
me of so much to get through and at that
pace we're not gonna get through I know
and if we spoke at a normal rate our
show would have to be three hours a
hundred percent we're giving you three
hours worth of news in a short
seventy-five minutes but in a third of
the time okay next up Nikki Bella reacts
to John Cena and dating another woman
okay
so said how did she find out I guess
just like with from the photo with
everyone else nikki bella's quote very
happy her ex-fiance John Cena is dating
again
despite her initial reaction on when on
Wednesdays episode of the Bellas podcast
she revealed that her stomach went into
knots when friends began texting her
articles about Cena and his new mystery
woman so quote I opened it up and when I
saw the photo it was weird she said
before sharing that her emotions quickly
took a turn quote sometimes when you got
a text or you see a photo or you see her
significant other flirt with someone
else you know you get those knots in
your stomach and it hurts yes Nikki it's
called a pit bull the pit we're very
familiar with the feeling you either
want to poop your pants immediately or
you just have the craziest time a cake
tummyache yes Pittsville Pittsville USA
at that point you got to move neither of
that happened to me she said when I saw
the big smile on his face with the
paparazzi photos I think that's why I
didn't want to [ __ ] my pants I felt
happy for him I'm very happy for him as
long as John's happy I'm happy even
though she took the high road when
learning up his new woman the former
wrestler said she will still raccattack
her in a heartbeat if she breaks John's
heart oh she's still protective of him
you guys Nikki Bella is like the
greatest girl of all time so mature and
I can only imagine like it's difficult
breaking up with someone and then
hearing through friends or like on
Facebook that they have a new partner
but like when you're famous like you see
that [ __ ] in high quality paparazzi
photos and that can not be easy no it
can't be easy but I feel like for her if
I were her I'd be glad when I saw that
picture too because also the woman I
think her name is Shay she's Vicky's
fella yes so it's not like John was so
grossed out by anything about the
direction you know it's just like this
little thing didn't work I'm gonna find
a similar version of you and if anyone's
gonna be pissed in the relationship it's
John because she's now dating her
Dancing with the Stars party she moved
on she knew she worked with while they
were dating so it's like that's weird
that would piss me off it's like you had
this close relationship with someone so
there are obviously feelings there while
we were together
it's like Marc and Rachel of Ross and
Rachel she's working with Marc she
swears there's nothing going on
but you know ii Ross wants to go on a
break or Rachel what's gonna break who's
she calling we should go like mark yes
yeah yeah it wasn't good but it did turn
out that mark really did have feelings
for Rachel so was Roth so crazy no he
wasn't
no so I think for Nikki don seenu's new
relationship is worse is best-case
scenario yeah I mean she was ready to
like fight a [ __ ] if it was like a
blonde wrestler you know she was ready
but then it was like oh you know this
isn't so bad and he seems happy and he's
a good dude and why couldn't they make
it work I know why they couldn't make it
work watch season 1 episode y total
Bellas you know John is one of those
guys he's a freak that's all they
shoulda just said that from the very
beginning like I love him yeah of course
but I don't know who I would put him
with it's like a we need to start a
matchmaking service I mean because we
have so many we have so many people that
we need to set up so the first person we
need to set up is Matt Harvey of course
pitcher for the Mets yeah and just
all-around like American Hero
mm-hmm John Cena I don't know if chunk
this girl's to the one for John Cena but
he's definitely we need to like make a
website and start a service for
celebrities who like don't know their
place in Hollywood I need a woman to
help them find it you know yeah or don't
know their place in Hollywood so don't
know like what level of celebrity they
think that is attainable for that I'll
feel like Olivia culpo
I know she's a hard one to play I was
just talking about the she businessman
Bo wait I was just talking about this
with Marco about a celebrity who like
their career was kind of stagnant and
they could have gone summer and if they
had just like dated someone it would
have helped because dating it's like
Nick and Priyanka it can be helpful wait
[ __ ] who was it it was really like okay
I can't remember but whatever so what
should our website be called we'll make
it on Squarespace it'll be called like
the snitches need dates or know-how that
doesn't rhyme
that's horrible okay I'm not the
wordsmith here okay like um like a toast
to love oh that's cute or also buddy
okay
matchmaker like coming with the toast
like to toast maker well that sounds
like a bread machine where you're gonna
make a toast ya know like um host man oh
man yeah yeah we'll work on it
well maker and Squarespace you can sign
up in your celebrity you need to have
like a madam
of a million followers before maybe
being sincere oh we're The Millionaire
Matchmaker but not dollar the Miller
Fowler matchmaker yes okay so guys we
use Squarespace actually we use it for
our camp toast website as well which is
coming soon maybe turn your cool idea
like our matchmaking service into a
website that showcases your work you can
blog publish content if you want to be
an interim influencer and start blogging
sell products services of all kinds you
own your domain they make it really easy
on Squarespace they help you buy the
domain design the website we've been
using it for free quite a few months
while our camp toasts web site is in the
works we can't wait for you guys to see
it so if you head to squarespace.com
slash toast you get a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your website
use the offer code toast to save 10% on
your first purchase of a website or
domain so that is squarespace.com slash
toast for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use offer code toast for
10% off I hope you enjoy that you know
this is the business woman's special
it's the moment you've been waiting for
just have a thought that I want to get
out about the Millionaire Matchmaker
because I have a call and I don't know
where I'll have an opportunity to say it
but Kristin Cavallari is best friend
then very Cavallari
I forgot her name looks like Patti
Stanger I don't know her best friend
I've actually in my life and never seen
an episode of it's quite enjoyable
Matchmaker right oh I mean a very
capillary I've seen every episode of
Millionaire Matchmaker it's good it's a
good show it deserves to be on the air
would you say it's a jolly good show I
would take some jolly good show I didn't
see last week's episode but um I I liked
it it makes the one when you moved to
Nashville more than anything ya know
I've been thinking a lot about moving to
Nashville in recent days I mean you know
where to find me when you're ready
no I know you came to me for real and
we're like do you want to move to
Nashville I mean my bags are legit pack
do you know why I wanted to now I'm
thinking about my income tax cuz its tax
it was only recently I follow Brittney
Kelly on Instagram who is Brian Kelly
not Brian Kelly the points guy Brian
Kelly one half of Florida Georgia line
his wife and they are between Nashville
and Florida and she was International
House and she was just like I want to
show you guys something and she went on
they live in a house like not in the
city and she went on her balcony same
with Kristin and Jay she went on her
balcony Jackie and she said put the
sound on and it was dead silent with
just like birds chirping and like the
wind blowing and they live on like this
beautiful like a little hill and it was
truly like such a special Instagram
story that I was like okay
we'll move I would imagine the CEO there
oh my god it's nothing but the birds in
the wind I know we really need to do it
except like what
except what natural is a perfect safe
for us yet because it's between LA and
New York it's between LA and New York
there's there's a lot of talent there so
we can we can easily do our show no
income tax we just have to get all the
steams you only the great part about New
York are the steamy vibes vibes can go
anywhere yeah like honestly honestly
let's do it I'm about to sign a new
lease should I not what still of another
year I could always break mine you know
you do one-year lease and then in a year
might all be up just kidding I won't
break it you guys think you don't like
this girl said no totally I think we
should we should really let's have
anything about it let's no we have to
look at find some houses yeah and an
argument that maybe rent or buy I think
maybe I could afford up to buy a house
and us yes but then also for a Libyans
act take how much they paying right and
show them what they could get in
Nashville forever me show Zack what
would Hartman in Nashville in the city
you can get like huge apartments exactly
in town whatever I said whatever house
though or I would want an apartment with
a nice outdoor space for Theo because
like the only I think a house is the
drag like so much work so much places to
clean lawns to mow except the grass is
great for do but if I had an apartment
with an outdoor space I would love that
no you have a car and he's a southern
boy at heart I would if we could find a
studio space I'm sure that we could have
we can build one in our garage right
because we've so much space space for
dates okay next up you'll never believe
who Mike the situation Sorrentino is
hanging out with in prison I actually
will believe because I saw it mitch is
hanging out with Billy McFarlane in the
big house Vinny and Pauly be stopped by
Sirius XM's the Jenny McCarthy show and
shed some light on how the situation is
handling his pretty prison sentence
the reality TV star turned himself in on
January 15th to begin his eight month
sentence despite not being home with his
wife Lauren or fellow Jersey Shore pals
he's doing quote so good up in Otisville
which is a male-only medium security
prison-- then he told Jenny McCarthy
that he and Pauly D talked to Mike every
day he explained that the stitches is
the same the stitch is the same and
before it's the same as before and they
talk through a special app and he has a
computer room that he can go through
throughout the day to clean totally The
Situation's communication
are hardly limited to this app program
from what it sounds like he's being as
social as ever the stars talked a bit
about who the sich hangs out with
according to the two friends one of his
prison companions includes fire
festivals disgraced founder Billy
McFarland McFarland was charged with
wire fraud on June 30th 2017 he was
sentenced to six years in prison it's
just so interesting how there are so
many prisons in the world and these two
like low-level Z list celebrities
blended in the same one yeah that is
crazy
I think Edina prison a lot lately
because it's just feel like it's a
pertinent topic of conversation every
channel might be going to prison yeah
and I just can't help a thing like of
how I would fare in prison and I just I
don't think good you know what I think
prison is what you make it you know and
I've been thinking about Lori Loughlin
in prison a lot because apparently
that's a reality that we'll all need to
face and it's like I some people go in
and they come out really like better on
somewhere it you know you learn you pet
you do your crime you pay your time you
got a habilitative yoga I think it very
much depends on the crime that you
committed and the prison that you go to
because I don't think all persons are
created equally
no one also I also think that like a
serial killer can necessarily be
rehabilitated you know right but then
you also watch well Wall Street and he
wants to avoid present at all costs he
finally goes and realizes white-collar
crime prison is basically Canyon Ranch
so it's I guess it's the prison that you
end up at that for sure I mean some of
them are like actual like slave like
camps like it's crazy it's crazy and
it's horrible and silent and and it's
rapey and it's not all orange is the new
black you know yeah some of its cycle oh
I don't watch our instances in the back
I thought orange is the new black is a
bad prison in the beginning they made it
seem like it was gangs and like towards
and it's a camp it's like it got like a
less bad prison I think that's like Game
of Thrones the beginning was [ __ ]
brutal and sexual and disgusting and now
it's it's like hey you're even come over
where you up you up since the Raven a no
I mean there's a lot of things about
prison that I am afraid of but most of
all it's like I feel like I would not
get good sleep in prison and like as
someone whose entire mood and like
productivity is based like I went to
that last Hannah 10 obviously it really
good I had 10 hours
wasn't and I feel so tired like it's not
enough and no amount of sleep will ever
be enough for me
and you have to make up very early in
prison and you're very bad mattresses
like they're not giving out purple
mattresses no you should be able to byom
you I imagine em for your little
mattress I have like I'm really just
someone whose entire life is incumbent
upon good long sleeps and on a good
mattress and for so long me and Ben were
on totally opposite pages cuz like he
likes are really hard bad cuz he like
he's a big man and that wants it's like
strain on his back and I just like want
to like lay in a big fluffy pillow
marshmallow and that wasn't an option
for me until court barbell so if you're
struggling to get a good night's sleep
you've got to get a purple mattress the
founders of purple are two brothers
hello who have been developing
cushioning technology for 30 years on
things like medical beds and wheelchairs
in 2016 they finally decided to use
their patented comfort technology to
create purple the world's most
scientific mattress you're gonna love
purple right now our listeners will get
a free purple pillow with purchase of a
mattress that's in addition to the great
free gifts they're always offering
site-wide text toast to eight four eight
eight eight the only way to get the free
pillow is to text tio ast two eight four
eight eight eight that's toast two eight
four eight eight eight trust me trust
what kind of mattress to Co like so he
likes the mattress between Ben's legs
oh I'm sure his wrist okay so you'll
hear something interesting about the UM
is we yes I do
so yeah Theo was crate trained yes which
means he sleeps in the crate and anytime
we have to leave him he stays in the
crate which has all of his blankets and
pillows and he loves it in there and
it's become his home we feed him in
there
he loves it and it's helped crates help
with like behavioral patterns and just
there's a lot of like good positive
attributes that come from a dog being
crate trained and once they get like one
or two what you starts like wean them
off it's like breast feeding you mean
them off the crate so now in the past
couple of weeks we've started to leave
Theo out and about in in the living room
and when we leave and I had the camera
now so I just make sure he's just
chillin and he usually just like mosey
around sleep but it's given him this
like newfound independence where it's
like when we used to go to sleep
he used to only want to lay in Ben's
armpit like right up our asses and it
was nice but it was a little annoying
like to sleep that way now every night
we're grabbing him wanting him to
with us he sleeps at the corner of the
bed all by himself with no one touching
him he's an independent woman yeah and
you know what it wasn't wasn't feasible
to have a dog that laid slept in your
armpit forever because it's so
uncomfortable so I'm glad that he's like
finding his way and we're really just
like coexisting I love him so much even
though I have a problem with coexisting
we're co-led big Toto thriving okay next
up we gotta get through to Ramona with a
YouTube TV deal discovery CEO David's a
vlog doubles down on streaming okay this
is exciting news for those of us who
have YouTube TV they are getting a bunch
of new networks with the addition of
discovery but it will also make the
subscription price higher that's still
less than cable Discovery will bring its
most popular channels to YouTube TV in a
multi-year distribution deal that
represents a major step in the company's
aggressive effort to showcase its
programming on streaming platforms what
we've been at this for the last five
years David's as lab Discovery's
president and CEO told Cheddar's John
cyber in an interview Wednesday we've
really been trying to grow our company
to be sustainable long-term growth
company starting on Wednesday yesterday
YouTube's live and on-demand
subscription service will stream eight
of Discovery's most popular brands the
discovery I'm sorry brands the Discovery
Channel HGTV Food Network TLC
Investigation Discovery Animal Planet
Travel Channel and Motor Trend and
Magnolia so yesterday also chip and Joe
announced their network within the
Discovery family I wonder if it's going
to be on YouTube TV or actual cable
probably both
why not YouTube TV now yes the Oprah
Winfrey Network which subarray owns
major stakin will begin streaming by the
end of the year this is just exciting
because I you guys know I have YouTube
TV I am a cord cutter for us I didn't
you're such a baloney I didn't choose to
cut my cords my husband cut them for us
and I have to say like I really I really
enjoy it and the only things I miss are
having CW on so I don't know Hulu and CW
but if you could get in talks with
YouTube and MTV by comm that I so I
can't keep up with siesta key and it's
like MTV's no longer on DirecTV
hmm they're having problems with
everyone they're having problems with
everyone head over to YouTube TV no yeah
no I have cable and I love it like I so
see the value in my package and I don't
and I also have a home phone and Wi-Fi
so it's all connected and it's like
better price on the other things for
that one for getting cable as well and I
don't have like the greatest I don't
have you know encore stars but I have
what I need to live I have Bravo and I
have E and I love cable and I know
everyone is like against cable it's like
if you pay for cable like you're
submitting to the man but I love cable
no I feel like cable they really take
advantage of you and it must end it's
frustrating but because you have all
that I think it makes sense for us we
have app we have every app we get I can
watch anything I want anytime because of
the Apple TV and all the different apps
but if I didn't have someone else's
cable logon I wouldn't be able to so I
don't know who's capable on do you we
use Zacks mom's and she has everything
right so it's like if you are a true
cord cutter I guess you're no no I'm not
because so how am I just an IDE what's
the point in having YouTube TV if you
don't have any logins for those apps if
I just had to subsist off of YouTube TV
alone I don't think I would starve yeah
so that's such a flawed system because
they make you cut cord but then they
make you also a cheat and use other
people so it's like each app like so
there's HBO now which is like you can
make an HBO login and you'll pay for HBO
like everything and all those apps put
together it's the same price as cable
I don't know people's really expensive
for my cable don't ask me how much but I
know it's extended for my king bowl my
Wi-Fi and my home phone I pay under like
$150 a month that's that's really good
yeah well for YouTube TV it's going up
to $50 a month so I should I should let
Zach know just in case want to go back
to cable oh my god imagine cute but
you're gonna move now are you gonna get
cable no we're happy I can't believe you
don't have cable only thing that I don't
have my father's me
yeah well the Wi-Fi was through the
building I will figure it out but you
know you're gonna need to the only thing
that I don't that I that I want for is
to be able to watch dynasty live okay I
have to wait till the next day but
that's the only thing I want for okay
did the final story before we bring out
this singer stinger is she here well
she's here okay
let's just wrap it up Amazon workers are
listening to what you tell Alexa a
global team reviews audio clips in an
output in an effort to help the
voice-activated assistant respond to
commands tens of millions of people use
smart speakers in their voice software
to play games find music or trawl for
trivia millions more are reluctant to
invite the devices and their powerful
microphones into their homes out of
concern that someone might be listening
sometimes someone is amazon.com Inc
employs thousands of people around the
world to help improve the alexa digital
assistant assistant powering its line of
echo speakers the team listens to voice
recordings captured an echo owners homes
and offices the recordings are
transcribed annotated and then fed back
into the software as part of an effort
to eliminate gaps in Alexis
understanding of human speech and help
it better respond to commands the Alexa
voice review process described by seven
people who have worked on the program
highlights the often overlooked human
role in training software algorithms in
marketing the target here's the thing I
don't care about Alexa listening to my
conversation it's like as long as they
don't give it to TMC that's the thing
they're allowed to listen to whatever
they want as long as they keep it within
their private company a public company
you can buy stocks oh then I'm a problem
with this no it was a privately held
company I would feel more secure but
it's like like now almost shit-talking
its public fodder or it's like if you
it's the government for some reason like
we're to decide that they want to take
you down they're gonna take the doors
down so they could go to Amazon and be
like and find just random [ __ ] about
that maybe they talked about doing drugs
or something you know wait wait can we
get on the same page for once I get it
sure had their beador I mean Heather
Dubrow one thousand percent said that
she was gonna take them a doors down
like there's literally no doubt in my
mind I don't know I was never sold on it
and that's such like a juvenile thing to
say that I couldn't I'm telling her I
know it's true obviously I hope she did
because she didn't take actually the
board doors took themselves down totally
they didn't need your help Heather um
also this morning I was using my Alexa
and I asked her to play dime-store
cowgirl and she is I'm sorry I don't
can't find anything for a dinosaur
cowgirl I was like oh she's brain dead
you need a new Alexa well you just had
someone else's Alexa once you said that
had someone's Alexa playing dime-store
cowgirl I didn't say it like though
right now so you're welcome yeah enjoy
and if you didn't here's a little taste
cuz I mean just a dime-store cowgirl
that's all I'm ever gonna be
you can take me out of the country but
you can take the country out of me no
okay we're gonna take a quick break if
you're watching on the YouTube stream
drop a comment for the one the only
ramona costa singer singer singer singer
we're gonna go grab her and we'll be
back we're talking all things ageless
all things we're Honi to drop a question
be right back
bye go get a snack
you
buckle up because we're about to go on
the Ramona coaster Ramona Singer queen
of Real Housewives of New York has
joined us she is here with her new
skincare line ageless by Ramona I've
been using it now for a week and I look
12 years old right I do baby before now
you look 10 well we were just talking
about it because it's a pretty good
price point how much is a bottle $40 and
it's huge like it's it's bigger than any
moisturizer that I bought at like
Sephora or any cosmetics right so it's a
serum that hydrates moisturizer place
anti-aging because all women stop they
stop losing collagen start losing
ecology and 23 years old and the whole
thing collagen you know people think oh
well Botox are Oh facelifts no you need
to build the city skin tone and hydrate
so this has all its the key ingredients
but trixl 3000 which is the highest
level you can get to build it has all
the peptides that urges with a harmonic
acid and has everything in it all the
antioxidants and listen my daughter is
my worst critic like mom what are you
doing why you wearing Wow what do you
think oh so he's just mom mom what your
skin just goes unbelievable this really
does work wow you thank you and she's
using it because she's issue 23 and it's
never too early to start never too early
and the proof is in the pudding you look
amazing you look amazing you have
inspired so much of our beauty regimen
because we went to we started going to
doctor sharing easy because of our you
because we were like we all need to get
Botox and we're like who looks amazing
like who is the best Botox oh wait wait
I was with her the other day because my
problem areas here my stomach it Jesus M
sculpting and this other which was
another machine yeah how insulin inside
yeah is what's really reduces the cuts
opens up the fat cells and dreams and
drains a point is I don't want to do
surgery so she said people are calling
us all the time tell us what did Ramona
do to raise yeah I know she had a
facelift she's like no she has it no you
call so good skincare
sunblock that's the water keeping your
face out of the Sun wearing hats
working out so when you're in the
Hamptons you don't put your face in the
Sun I wear a hat and I put sunblock on
got it well I'm loving watching you you
look so good and it's so crazy because
episodes of Real Housewives season one
air and you really have like aged
perfectly okay like and in a way that I
feel like everyone should age aging is
not a bad thing but you want to do an
integrates away and having to keep that
skin tight
of HS by Ramona yeah it's great so you
get on a Gaspar mother calm a just $39
and you'll see I mean I've already
gotten comments on my Instagram and from
people how it's changed their skin they
see a big difference after a couple of
months so excited to try it so I just
feel like Ramona and that makes me feel
better on the inside when I was in
Ramona do right WW Rd what would Ramona
do exactly so we really think of it
right now oh yeah New York searches
we've got Barbra did you did you know
Barbra before you know I knew of Barbra
we were never that friendly and I meet
so many people and it's really it's kind
of annoying to me oh you don't remember
me look hello I need a thousand people
today so I mean unless you know a good
friend of mine or I'm doing business
with you how am I gonna remember
somebody met twice sure that's
frustrating yeah does she ever make it
to full housewife status this season
no she's called a friend what do you
think that they're gonna give it another
go next season or this was a shot that
this was it this was it okay what do you
think of her how do you think she's
doing I was enjoying her up until this
episode because I think like she came in
and she was just you and her and a head
made progress and it was a few steps
backwards one said she had to come in
but I think in general she's a good
friend and she gives good advice but she
was being petty about the shark room
what is it about that shark right now I
was up being dead what's not being said
that's what I put on my Twitter list
links I actually stayed home to watch
the show and I really enjoyed watching
it and I said what's what's it about the
fish room that we don't like it seems
like someone's not saying something like
herpes I'll tell you exactly what it is
it's a boy's room okay and we're all
very feminine women and listen every
room is beautiful I'll be happy to stay
in the sharp core the fish room but it's
just like a joke because we all like the
other [ __ ] listen she has like seven
bedrooms right right I mean one bedroom
is more nicer than the rest yeah that's
the least nice and it's still nice it is
nice it's really funny it's a joke so we
all rather be in the other rooms than
that well it's it's rare now that we're
fighting about rooms and you and Sonia
aren't really at the center of the
argument cuz that's always what happens
right and Ramona stuff I didn't you and
Sonia start that but you and Sonia are
rooming together now in the Berkshires
yeah we had fun too do you think there
will ever be a time where you and Sonia
aren't rooming together I don't think so
I mean I think was there one time we
roomed together though we always end up
together you know right
it's just something that Sonia and I we
have this dynamic when we go away
you know like the Rini likes to go to
bed early get up early so you're not go
to bed late get up play your the
travelers yeah we giggle at night we
review and giggle about what happened
the night before you know so just we
just have fun we're very entertaining
together I love watching you guys yeah
so that usually in the berkshires
there's major drama it seems like this
time it's not so bad like because next
week looks like it's just fun like drunk
fun everyone's like getting naked right
so is there a big fight or is this do
you guys break this curse um well you
have to watch the show to see did you
break share the curse see you break sure
the course that's good like that well no
wait the last time we were talking about
your skincare line bran last season
Bethenny came for you and she said you
didn't have a formula or a lab right did
you send Bethenny a bottle of ageless by
Ramona you know what no you didn't know
what was the reasoning part what was the
reasoning behind that you know Bethenny
is like a cat you just don't know even
she's gonna strike out it you were next
to you so I respect that to me very much
I think she respects me we're not the
closest of friends who somehow our
dynamics are always like kind of strong
other but I know when we were filming
you know she actually put some on and
you know she saw that I was I had the
bottle and she put some on her face and
you know Bethenny's Bethenny you know
yeah yeah but you are not wearing skinny
girl jeans today no my favorite Jean in
the world is La Jolla I have I have so
many of their jeans they raise your butt
up they're good they're great jeans and
they last a long time I mean they're not
exactly inexpensive I think they're not
they're over there like $200 jeans but
you know what you wear them all the time
like buying a good handbag right yeah
yeah and these jeans I've had for three
years and my daughter that's my daughter
stole some of my cheese she's great we
mix the laundry that's like a where I
wonder where the dark ones the really
dark ones and she took them how's Avery
she's great she's well she's so smart
yeah she's very smart yeah that's so
cool we love her we see her around a lot
yeah and you must have a great
relationship she kind of grew up on the
show yeah she started when she was a 12
years old and what is her relationship
with like it now cuz she doesn't - she
live with you know she's her own place
right and she works so does she like
filming well she doesn't only have time
to film because she's working now right
it's a working girl and uh and she works
late and she has things to do so I mean
once in a while she'll come on the show
if we're doing like a big party or
something just show up you know for
something important you know I think was
the announcement of
party for the Wayans wedding after the
wedding oh right and you know so she
fell he filmed something at her I think
Bonwit teller social film now and then
yeah so I was getting a pedicure
yesterday and I was walking in behind
this man and we both sat down next to
each other and it was Harry Dubin oh my
god Harry called me like I have to say
he's very handsome he said you know he's
a really he's a bad rap but I'm like
we're just good friend he was so nice to
everyone I was just watching his every
move he's very a pedicure next massage
pedicure head massage no polish just
like foot rub scrub the whole thing but
I was just very charming I understood
why everyone was like so obsessed I mean
he really was so handsome and it's just
so funny how he got this rep on the show
but like he's a very tall he is a
presence to him and I was really very
charm he's very elegant he's a gentleman
fact of two weeks ago he took myself out
with Avery and her girlfriend we was
down to dinner at dirty laundry and the
meeting for some drinks after and he's
really I mean he's a great guy I've
always gotten along with fun era when
everyone was saying obsessed with Harry
Dubin
I've never dated him well this friend I
was gonna say well there ever be a time
where we could see miss Ramona Zhu Ben I
didn't think so I mean we just I mean I
love him I do I love them so much and I
know we're gonna be friends forever I
feel like you loved love being single
you know what that's a very good
question I was thinking about that I
don't know if I love being single but
embrace it I think it agrees with you
yes look at your face yeah well just my
Ramona I just think you know I think
it's really important I think once
you're married you have your child you
know a lot of nice ones they got
different to go how to able to recover
and this and that and I just first of
all it's my girlfriends I have great
girlfriends were married and they
embrace me constantly come to dinner
with us we have this party they didn't
like say oh she's single dad we can't
have her around they embrace it and
there are people who are like that so
they never did that so that was good
then I've met new women that are single
in our divorce and they've embraced me
and I've embraced them in fact this is
one woman I love our name is Christine
she has gems bye Christine actually
wearing her piece right now beautiful
you know a shout out so not only she's
beautiful the outside inside the only
does she do beautiful jewelry gems bye
Christine but women supporting other
women yeah I have fun with moving to ask
him together we're like you know
flirting with men together it's just
like cuz if a great man comes along okay
I'm
for if it doesn't happen it doesn't
happen but it'll happen it'll happen
also what's so interesting in great
about the New York housewives right now
is pretty much all of you are single and
that doesn't happen in any other
franchise and I think you always see it
at the Reunion where everyone really
comes together and like yes you all
fight but you have each other's back as
you're all like in it together how do
you think like from when the show
started where everyone really was a
housewife for the most part to where you
guys are now how much it has changed a
mission well that's an excellent
question well you know I've been on the
show now for I started filming literally
what 12 13 years ago that's so crazy and
what this is season what 11 or 12 I came
I love it me neither
so listen this our show real awesome you
feel it definitely reflects life it
reflects life so you know just like your
your friends you know if you have fear
and your 40s or your 50s you have
friends that are getting to forests I
have maybe their spouses died yeah
things happen and in life is ever
changing and that's what makes our show
so great so people always say your show
has to be scripted you know not script
you can't make up this stuff you just
can't make it up totally I loved
watching all you guys fly to LA and go
to Andy's baby shower oh my gosh that
was okay that was an iconic event it
truly was I'm Donna Karan I mean all the
OGIS from each show or on any show that
special Christmas show and that's when
you found out and when he announced so
he said we have to have a shower for him
so he's through it together last minute
and it was no one will ever have a
shower like that no no I'm here who you
are could be the queen of England you're
not having a shower like that everyone
it was beyond who did you meet from
other franchises that you connected with
well I got to know Lisa Rena a lot
better well I could see you guys just
like taking the town ripping it down I
really got a Mike Kyle I've always
gotten along with always known always
and toward her but I could really got to
know Lisa and actually all the ladies
like I got to talk to they're all
everyone we were all there first of all
for a common reason Andy we all love and
that's true and that right there brought
such good energy into the room or good
synergy so you watch the other shows
yeah but I can't watch it religiously
because this to me shows there's have
you been watching Beverly Hills right
now puppy gate well I heard about I mean
I yeah I would love to know what side
nobody was even on savanna pump or team
everyone else oh maybe they're just well
this is not what happens I Verona you
can't do nothing have you met Lisa
Vanderpump what is Wow
yeah what did she like um no I think you
know I think she's a little Lisa's Lisa
she's in her own world I think I think
the problem is that she likes to control
everything and now she got busted on
something right and it's like okay how
she can get out of this or you know
who's gonna get their own the backlash
on this and I think she's used to being
in control and now she could she got
caught with her pants down
yeah how should those pants back up and
you guys have had similar problems in
New York with page six articles with
Tinsley and and of all the women that
you filmed with who do you think was
selling the most stories or continues to
sell the most or not even sell justice
you know listen I'm telling you I don't
know if anybody sells stories I mean I
know I just go somewhere and it's
written on page six the next day and I
know it's none of my counterparts on the
show I just think our show has become
such a bigger-than-life that people just
randomly phone things in and take photos
I agree control crazy it is do you find
it difficult to date in New York when
the show was like such a spectacle well
yeah I mean actually one or two months
out you know I can't date you because
you know I don't want to be on page six
right you know it's a lot so are you
dating I'm dating yeah one person or
many the man in the red scarf this
morning no he and I crying Krauss and I
aren't just really great friends we
actually went to a Rory from platinum
poivre she had a she has a book called
um something dating just came out with
it and she had a book party at this um
gallery so he was there with his with
his current girlfriend whoo yes who's
very lovely and Rory so yeah we're
friendly I was just going to dinner with
him afterward with his girlfriend but
then I had to go home at Avery which was
um you know I rather do that you know
what happens is I meet a lot of men and
I go out with them but you know I'm not
gonna just go out to go out so I'll go
out three four times and then maybe we
just become friends or you know I know
what I want at this point in my life and
you know what I'm not gonna get what I
want then why bother I feel like you
have endless amounts of energy do you go
out every night well I purposely stayed
in last night and did watch out of me
for you know because I usually would
they send us the episode a week in
advance and I used to get DVDs I could
put in a nice big screen now I watched
my little my little thing and I have to
look and I was so amused by the
Berkshire episode that I said I have to
watch using the
organ letters right that I was I don't
think I've ever laughed hard and all
right you understand they work real
letters they were just pretend left they
were oh I put that on my Twitter too
yeah I thought they were genuine list
there were plexiglass you know yes touch
engaged they were state that's the word
they were stage letters that is made for
comedy is there anyone who's not on the
show anymore that you're still close
with are you still friends with Carroll
yeah we talk I see her yeah I love Carol
absolutely what I chose why the team I
was never that close to her yeah
you never enough time yeah I thought you
know your amount of time you know yeah I
mean Heather I love Heather we don't see
each other that much but I stay in
contact with her army Aviva I do like
Aviva I don't really see her that much
anymore but you know I see her were very
friendly I'll run into her socially have
you been to Luann's cabaret show since
the first Johnny one loved it I loved it
I went to the one at the Fillmore and
Miami
oh she was fabulous I just went and
that's where I saw it right into these
fabulous I've been out like twice ready
I want to go again it's just such a good
time yeah it's a real upper she's funny
and I said to her because the first show
I saw was like what a year or two ago
and she's evolved but I like about it
now is she's truly a one-man show so
it's basically all about her she's very
self-deprecating she's really funny I
loved it I don't want it to end I
enjoyed it I'm glad you enjoyed it I
like to - I have a question for you you
have so many on conic lines on the show
what is the line that people like when
people see you like what did they screen
it what's the one line that people say
the most because for us it's Wow
Bethenny dress Wow when I say that six
times or you are not a woman who
supports other women right what do
people scream at you the most yeah those
are it and then you really have like
just been such an integral part of house
my sister turtle time of course of
course
of course you're hilarious like a fine
wine better with time Oh what is what is
your strategy for coming up with your
tag lines because they really are very
good you come up with them all yourself
why oh so I live out this my girlfriend
Nicole tuna kiss helps me a little bit
actually help me with the one that which
was the one last year it's mind over
matter if you don't mind I love I'm an
acquired taste if you don't like me a
cry right a help with that one too
because she doesn't really watch the
really good bf than she knows me so
they do a really good job of just
capturing your vibe alright first us to
give suggestions and they kind of edit
them got it yeah I love it
it was my line this year Oh oh my god I
mean I mean I don't remember too much
ether Orissa so I think about like I
won't settle for less or so oh oh oh the
only thing I'll settle for is more
that's a good one to know likes I'm very
competitive with me myself and I that's
the way to be yeah well you're winning
in the skincare Department HS by romona
is available at ageless by romona comm
it's $40 a bottle yeah okay I highly
recommend it I've been using it for a
week and people keep telling me that I
look like a prepubescent teen so I
highly recommend it Thank You Ramona for
coming or ever my question Ramon on into
a mature Instagram Ramona Singer an
ageless by Ramona Instagram yeah
everything is yeah and then right so my
Twitter Instagram Facebook it's all
sugar thank you for being here Ramona
thank you guys for being here we are
doing a podcast episode tomorrow as we
are heading to Coachella today so pray
for us and just be thinking of us this
weekend what are you wearing it could
shell is it where's resonate question I
brought my HS by Ramona so I'll be okay
thank you guys for being here we will
see you tomorrow have a good day
[Music]
you